hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dead space 3
now this is a game that I've been
incredibly excited to play because I
fell in love with the first two dead
space games they were above and beyond
everything that I was expecting and from
what I got from the demo that I played
earlier I think dead space is gonna be
dead space 3 is gonna be a worthy
addition to the franchise so let's dive
right into it since I am a bit I'm
pretty used to dead space I'm actually
gonna play this on hard not impossible
just yet I'll save that for a livestream
or something but I do want to challenge
when I play this because like I love the
dead space mechanic said I want to be
able to do 300 years ago with the
discovery of the black marker an alien
artifact found under the old gulf of
mexico on earth it seemed to hold the
promise of limitless energy until it
produced dementia insanity and a twisted
life after death known as Necromorphs
the details of the original black-market
disaster were buried in cover-ups and
conspiracies but not before an entire
religion could be launched in the name
of one of its researchers Michael Altman
his questionable death turned him into a
martyr and unit ology was born to this
day it thrives a secretive organization
that believes the markers are divine and
their plan for us
a glorious unity of mind body and spirit
generations after the black market
disaster mankind found himself going
extinct from lack of resources desperate
he sought to replicate the black market
in an attempt to harness its limitless
energies for himself the records of this
era are unclear but we now know the
replication was successful but the cost
too high
the marker copies were all buried hidden
in secret places across the universe
where to all our benefit they might have
stayed but 200 years later during an
illegal mining operation on Aegis 7 the
planet cracker USG Ishimura on earth to
one of the Forgotten copies
a red marker and with it the start of a
new wave of Mark infections a key
survivor of that incident was an
engineer named Isaac Clark that Marcus
spoke to him and let him with a gift a
mental wound print of the marker itself
[Music]
Isaac was captured and tortured by earth
goth his mind harvested for the marker
secrets the marker program was thus
restarted and a new one built on the
populous Titan sprawl
the disaster quickly followed he managed
to escape but just barely
left but dust just by Aegis ever since
that time the marker crisis is only
deepened and Isaac Clark his marker
touch mines still burning with the
ability to build or destroy them stays
in hiding determined to retreat from the
markers and all they evolved
but there is hope
a backwater ice ball of a planet
we're 200 years ago someone somehow
stopped to mark uprising in its tracks a
clue from the past that may save our
future
you
all right so are officially caught up on
the story if you've watched the other
game or played for yourself you pretty
much got the the most of that but that
leads into what's going on right now
well I may have to fade out here again
I'm slipping from reality no I'm really
excited about this game because I don't
know what it is but something about the
mechanics of the game just works for me
I really appreciate the style of the art
and the story itself I've actually read
the books I have it's really an
interesting back story that they got
about um Altman the book one of the
books was about almond himself and it
was just really interesting read okay
it's this Isaac Clark er is this the
other guy don't know who that is
alpha Niner this is whiskey two five
zero alpha Niner this is whiskey
two five zero Serrano do you read me oh
thank god did you find it doc I'm not
even sure what we're looking for I can't
tell you anymore dang it
[Music]
okay so am i playing as this guy wow I
am okay this must be some backstory on
what the planet is all about let's see
what have I got here I've got something
and about and about no ammo absolutely
no ammo so let's just hurry our way on
one before I get any further I want to
change something here I need to turn on
subtitles just so it's easier for you
guys to tell what the dialogue is so
Anna
there we go yeah I notice you kind of
need ammo buddy yeah wonder who this guy
is because obviously he has no heart no
oh hell-oh he has no real part in
Isaac's story he's probably just some
soldier from the planet that they're on
probably going to explain how the
infection starts hello I don't want to
get inside I don't even know what this
is is this a Shimura good alright okay
it looks like they're just gone with the
standard ammo clips which is what they
were doing before if I have to break
guard off not Isaac Clark but I'm still
a badass yeah let me shoot this sumbitch
there we go don't know why whoa hello
I might be a little worried about that
okay these are definitely Necromorphs if
I'm not mistaken there it's going to be
a lotta more variety to the enemies no
it's pitch black in here whoa what the
oh hi this guy panicking and screaming
and I'm here just being a badass guess
I'm too used to Isaac Clark baby hello
come on man this gun does not have any
ammo
there's no clip capacity as far as I can
tell okay this guy's definitely not
Isaac Clark I'm out I'm almost out of
Health already whoa okay so far so good
this guy is obviously not anywhere near
as tough as Isaac Clark is and I don't
know what gun is using but as you guys
saw in the weapon customization when I
play the demo if you saw that there's
like untold amounts of just variations
aha codex found it oh boy
Oh God whoa hello okay well maybe here's
a badass look at him go okay yeah don't
stop for anyone office oh hang on man
this is cool this is like a [ __ ]
adventure game right here I mean I
always thought that the guys official
studios were very creative what is that
Oh
this guy seems to have God no I'm
actually playing here Judith I no wonder
I need to shoot something this guy seems
to have the same amount of luck that
Isaac Clarke has yep right in the hole
[Music]
Wow
probably just cuz I'm playing him
because I'm such a badass alright get up
buddy
your soldier get on your feet we got
word don't take your helmet off that's
exactly not what you need to do all
right come on boy
man this kid's got to be young whoa
hello
that's not normal they want to consider
putting your helmet back on
like where is this doctor that he's
talking okay where's dr. Serrano Oh
girls run always the optimist yeah well
he said I should take this into the city
he said there's still time to stop it
sir there's still time I lost control I
know for the love of Earth
and in the sovereign colonies we've got
to do what's right blow everything up
I'm guessing you love the earth son your
mom and dad
that's a commotion elects boy good glad
to hear bang bang
this guy's gonna yep I knew it
man poor guy poor kid he had potential I
like most of the other characters
besides Isaac Clark he gets the back
into the deal and I think this guy's
setting some sort of self-destruct going
on here
ah but I said self-destruct I didn't
mean it like that
[Music]
and I didn't know that a codex could
ghost thermonuclear on this oh no it's
just deleting it okay never mind then
alright then we're off to an interesting
start not exactly sure what's gone on
just yet but I'm sure the pieces will
come together later shut up [ __ ]
wait 200 years later oh okay I'm
starting to get it Oh No
oh I fixed bent too deep into the bottle
crazy from the marker I have to say that
I am very impressed with the graphics of
the this overtime like No so I'm trying
not to interrupt anything important oh
hello that's the co-op guy
don't have a lot of time so I'm gonna
make this brief I understand you're
something of an expert on markers you
created one I don't make [ __ ] your
government made me and you destroyed too
which is why we're here
okay sure thing Unitologist have
breached the intercom course unless you
help me okay sounds like a plausible
reason to get going I could understand
why Isaac would wanna okay shut himself
away
he's like consumed by his own insanity
poor guy probably destroys any
possibility for him to have a connection
with another person but I mean that's
just part of the problem that's why
that's why I love him as a character I'm
glad they gave him a voice in the second
game because I'd love the voice actor
though I'm I mean I I have an
appreciation for voice acting okay cue
to use a quick medpac whoa what what
hurt me follow those [ __ ] wherever
that other guy is he's the he's the
other guy I think I don't think they're
there are save points anymore in the
game I think they're mostly just
auto-saves
we've lost a part as ourselves during
the nightmare on the Titan sprawl for
Elliot was her I luckily we found a
replacement we can afford even though
the duck caller doesn't quite match at
least you can feel whole again oh this
is a journal me I lost a part of my soul
and there's not a damn thing I can do to
get that back I guess ultimately that's
why she left people want things they can
fix and I'm permanently broken all right
so this is like this rents past you okay
that's not too important I'm just
looking for anything else in this
apartment that might be important before
we get going I'm gonna try to keep the
story moving
how long has she been missing oh shut up
get over here okay [ __ ] oh you shut
up all right let's see here
so Unitologist are running hello I even
have as a weapons battalion what do you
mean last means last genius as in no
more left really looks like an earth
gusts falling off part boy I can crouch
now that's new I don't remember that
being in the demo Oh splattering heads
people can't handle my plasma cutter why
bring an actual gun to a fight sorry my
aims a little rusty haven't actually
played an honest-to-god shooter in a
while I mean not that this is an
honest-to-god shooter you want some
[ __ ]
yeah that's called fanatical devotion
right there actually that doesn't make
sense a Unitologist wouldn't want to
destroy his body
hello ammo I'm kind of disappointed in
the unified ammo system oh hello
no head Splosion it is interesting
because I'm actually fighting other
people
I don't I I'm not used to fighting
humans in this game I mean it's to be
expected when the whole world goes crazy
people turn on each other on a dime
especially when you got fanatics like
this I mean people who believe oh hello
no suicide bombers all over the place
why because I can destroy markers okay
that spot like does not look good I need
to get away from that spotlight you're
not get caught in that okay come on come
on help me out here
oh it's following me and everyone it's
got to go here we go applo will find
more monsters is interesting I mean I
absolutely I actually really like the
idea of varied environments because the
problem with the first dead space was
that it was all the same place I mean
the Ishimura was scary and tight corners
and everything but it was all the same
okay yeah convergence I can stop
[Applause]
okay sounds good to me let's go buddy
hang on
things are looking different I don't
know when there are lockers of Rennicks
oh come on I was right here buddy
you'd have been a little more patient I
could have not had that lady die well
Pat's bloating whoa
don't stop I've still got my stasis unit
I slowed the traffic and get across Jen
man whoa hello
that's not what I meant by slowed the
traffic Jesus okay I just [ __ ] up
everything even that well I love you as
a clerk all right like I said before I
really think this particular voice actor
adds a lot of character to who Isaac
Clark is I think he's a perfect fit for
the idea that this guy's a deeply
troubled but also snarky and sarcastic
and very intelligent person he's just
got a lot weighing on his mind that's a
problem
all right let's go come on oh this looks
good
[Applause]
aha yes sure why danik blames them for
experimenting with the more no I'm
almost there
stop giving me [ __ ] I'll be there in my
own time thank you very much
I don't know why my helmets down why the
hell did I take my helmet off I mean
damn I am one handsome [ __ ] but
come on think sensibly here I'm popping
heads left and right wow what a wait did
I never have a helmet I don't even know
why would you take him out and then
leave one alive ah game logic ow
please don't do that to me don't waste
your energy you're going to be dead in a
matter of minutes pick him up
that voice actor sounds familiar yeah
see that it's a marker test lab they're
everywhere at all the major colony is an
alpha
are you all for me as part of the marker
test program Isaac you helped make and
today you of all people get to watch me
set them free great No you'll kill
everyone yeah the beginning Isaac nature
must take its course and I can't allow
you or anyone else to stop there shut up
[ __ ] and here come the Necromorphs
and now it's time for you to join the
cycle of rebirth how about you go [ __ ]
yourself buddy oh do I get to do
something here how I fall on a pile of
bodies that's what I do
yeah kind of grody man he's had worse
actually poor guys been through hell and
back
duh my mother Clark that didn't hurt at
all just losing my mind two-bit wait who
the hell are you
Oh already man that was fast I was like
really really really doing okay you go
[ __ ] yourself up headshots aren't gonna
work against these guys oh you twins in
your leg coming off Jesus Christ
come on man I cut him in half before I
cut off his [ __ ] leg
Jesus Papa's bull that guy did not want
to die
okay I don't know man this must be like
exponentially fast for that market I
mean it's obviously a gigantic ass
marker but I mean for them to pop up
already I don't know how long I was
unconscious for but oh my goodness okay
good I still have my Kinesis module yeah
thank you
and with it everything has begun to go
to hell which is just how I Isaac Clark
like it you know you got a feel for this
guy I mean he's he's almost permanently
mentally disturbed I mean there was a
reason he was in a straightjacket locked
up okay come on bear your leg popped up
that's normal that's not normal I mean
nothing about these people are normal I
should say but um if we're being totally
serious here whoa
man these guys are more persistent than
I remember
I hope I have enough ammo for that I
think I've collected quite a bit and not
enough like most of the other games or
both other games has only been to the
plasma cutter is proving to be the most
useful it's a really versatile tool
obviously pretty much I bet you could go
through all the games on the hardest
difficulties with just the plasma cutter
in fact I believe I thought I heard a
noise in fact I believe there are there
are achievements associated with no
Washington stations not far I could ride
one of the trains out sounds good I
don't even know where I am what planet
or what colony I'm on obviously not
Earth but someplace where the
Unitologist have a pretty good foothold
out sorry
hello Unitologist artifact
huh all right I don't have time to read
all that I'm not gonna be reading
although everything that comes by
because there's gonna be a lot of lot of
lot of lot of backstory going on and I
kind of want to get through the game
primarily because if you haven't notice
these are gonna be 30 minute episodes
and I want to be able to get through the
story as quickly all right Oh screw you
buddy
[Music]
yeah okay whoa whoa hey I should have
noticed when the music picked up a bit
give me that oh that's nothing oh you're
an ugly one HM yeah like I said before
there's gonna be a lot more variety to
the models shut up oh boy here comes one
good oh that was a Miss come on Oh give
me a plate Jesus Christ there we go oh
man it's definitely a lot more intense
and I remember where the [ __ ] did you
come from these guys are all over the
place
holy balls my my stasis does not last
long Jesus Christ
these guys are all over the place all
right nothing
ain't no problem for Isaac Clark it kind
of does seem like my plasma cutter is a
lot wimpier than it has been in the past
wait hang on what's that over there
ah [ __ ] I do our Glee app oh you can
throw spikes that's is a total dick move
giving them more powers day by day it's
not fair I tells you no thank you I
don't want any you're not dead
don't even try thank you I'm carrying
one of these with me because I'm gonna
run it oh man
it's much harder it was much easier to
grab the hello goodbye thank you it was
much easier to grab the progress in case
you didn't know they used the the level
screens in the door loading for uh-huh
for level loading and there we go
autosave going on no of course not
well I'm an engineer okay yeah I lost
him in a panic this outbreak may buy us
some time I am grabbing a train looks
like the Train was getting refitted with
a new powered car uh-huh don't mind me
just assembling my train
screw you yeah yeah yeah yeah I know how
to do it I'm a non-expert
engineer with every single possible
engineering tack tasks possible
including trained engineering totally
logical well I guess when it's as easy
as this and when you have a
super-powered Kinesis module you can do
anything
wait I need to get on that I need to I
need to get on that rear the Train you
got it buddy here we go all right let me
guess that there's going to be some
diabolical Horrors waiting for me on
this train being shocked out the some
secret coordinates and then we lost
contact I know your ex-girlfriend very
well she's still alive that's how we
have found her yet
I'm wondering why Ellie would work for
these EarthGov people hello what was
that
ah okay
are you that co-op guy which ship is at
your door oh you guys I didn't even see
you popping up your easier to kill
I'm kind of just watching the spectacle
I'm not paying attention to everything
around me here boom head shout and I'm
not looking so good I really need a
helmet Isaac come on man where's your
super suit I mean you had to still have
all the credits stored up that's who you
are you shotgun almost killed me
i'm-a-comin don't leave me you bastards
i'm-a-comin
I'm a-comin well
thanks Brett
[Music]
not bad not bad at all and tired and in
pain which is a familiar feeling for the
badass that is Isaac Clark well that
sucks hi [ __ ] you too hey even
understand how many things I've killed
YouTube here alright this is as good a
place as any
just Oh chapter 1 is already done that
was all of chapter 1 if it's anything
like the past dead space games there's
gonna be 12 chapters I don't expect to
get through a chapter each episode here
but this is a good place to stop it
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you guys are looking forward to more
because this should be a great game and
if you're waiting to play the game I
exert this you play the game in a couple
days because it's gonna take me a long
time to get through this well not a long
time but at least a week or two so thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]
Oh
[Music]